and I think what we're seeing in the
healthcare industry is we're exposing
the flaws right so the hospitals can't
handle this many cases there's tons of
supply chain issues around personal
protective equipment all of these things
even I saw you tweeting about the
telemedicine is being overwhelmed with
people who don't actually want to go
into a physical location but can't keep
up with demand like how do you think the
world changes in the healthcare side
kind of once we get out on the other
side of this so right now it's kind of
let's solve this problem but how does
healthcare and that industry really
change over time because of it well a
bunch of ways that are predictable and
then a bunch of ways we can't predict
one of the one of the things that I'm
most excited about is that there will be
a whole bunch of good news coming out of
the bad news you know even the world war
two produced a number of inventions I
think radar was one of them I'm not good
on history but I think that was one and
what we just did and we're doing right
now is we're putting the best minds in
the world medical and scientific
together and they're working on a
problem that's sort of a class of
problems you know they won't just learn
about this they'll they'll learn about
you know the larger group of this and
what that produces you can't predict but
we're putting the smartest people in the
world together we're networking them
they'll know each other after this is
done they'll probably create platforms
for a better sharing of information that
is has almost unlimited potential for
where that can go and it's just because
you you know put the brains on the same
places
I mean it's it's the same it's the same
thing that happens with Silicon Valley
it's the same thing that happens with a
Microsoft town a bunch of geniuses move
there and then you've got the right
situation for startups right maybe they
came to work for Microsoft but now they
start dating each other and you know
cross pollinating and suddenly hey I got
an idea it doesn't fit in Microsoft I'm
gonna go start my own company so you're
going to see something like happened in
the startup world by having them all in
one place really important you know the
cross-pollination is just essential
that's why you don't see a startup
community
like spring up in the middle of Idaho or
something it's it's the people
connection makes it happen so we just
did that by necessity with them with the
top smartest scientists the medical
community that's going to turn into
something the other thing is that I feel
as I was close to guaranteed that there
will be some red tape that's removed
because we're removing some red tape
temporarily in a number of ways and some
of it we're going to say you know it'd
work better without that red tape let's
just keep it that way so some of it will
be that kind of improvement will
certainly be toughened against pandemics
will certainly have better plans for the
next one will certainly have better
ability to flex Wells will certainly be
moving our drug pipeline from China to
the United States guaranteed there's
just no chance that's not happening and
by the way if you hear that your
government is not making that happen
change your president find one that will
that's not optional anymore
all right good I think you can count on
President Trump doing it and whoever
else if we get another president I think
you could count on than doing it as well
any party at this point it's just a
given
so that'll happen and then I was early
on I was suggesting that we drop the
licensing requirements across state so
that telemedicine people a doctor in
Utah that is not yet as a big problem
could take some calls from people in
let's say New York City who are at the
moment it's illegal why is it because
New York City thinks that a doctor in
Idaho is not qualified well maybe you
should talk to his patients because they
think they are they think these doctors
aren't qualified I don't think in the
context of an emergency there's any
argument whatsoever that makes any sense
they should keep that restriction so at
least temporarily get rid of it and what
will happen if they temporarily get rid
of that restriction I will answer the
question people will realize there was
no reason for it in the first place
you know it had to do with I know lobby
groups or the AMA or some damn reason
that had to do with the economics of
doctors
but not the well-being of patients you
know so I think you'll see things like
that that are temporary reductions in
regulations but they'll become permanent
so I would expect actually a pretty big
game now consider also the the fact that
we're all getting trained for hygiene
what is the world going to look like
with all these habits we've developed
for a good hygiene I'll be washing my
hands immediately after this because I
just coughed my hand I don't have the
virus by the way I just if I talk too
much I it's just my normal baseline so
don't worry about it so a hygiene better
hygiene what's that going to do to the
normal flu what are we gonna how are we
going to treat the normal flu now that
we found all these treatments that
apparently are going to work for this
specific coronavirus do they work for
every virus you know will we end up
taking hydroxy clawed up old blue that's
the official name I think I nailed it
hydro clock sleep whatever will we start
taking that for regular flu and then
people will say well it's a good thing
we had this other flu because we went to
known this really helps and the regular
flu is whacking people by the you know
tens of thousands and hundreds of
thousands so if I had the guess we're
going to come out of this with all kinds
of new capabilities and streamline
processes things we didn't know we
needed and we're going to be hardened
for the next challenge yeah generally
with you in terms of there's like these
regulation improvements that will get
mainly because in times of emergency or
necessity we just woke aynd of ignore
regulation and then realize oh wait that
could have been not there in the first
place I actually think the way people
work is very similar right all of a
sudden people realize wait a minute I
don't think we all actually need to go
to this office right and some of this
remote work or from home and the tools
etc could could actually suffice
I saw a joke arm arm that said maybe we
don't actually need all those meetings
they could have just been emails right
and then people realized that not only
just work from kind of how they work
changes but then there's the economy as
well and obviously I think there's a lot
of people who are
kind of worried that the economy is
gonna grind to a halt
mainly because people are being
encouraged to not leave their homes so
it's not a hair don't have enough money
it's more of a you can't leave your home
and therefore your economic activity is
gonna fall off a cliff how are you
thinking about you know coronavirus
impact on the economy and kind of where
we are right now well here's where
people who don't have any background
with economics are at a great
disadvantage because they they have just
less vision on the problem and so I
would think it looks scarier because you
hear people who don't know much about
economics say it's all falling apart and
if you don't know any better
you might believe them but I have a
degree in economics I've got an MBA from
the top school and I've talked to lots
of other people who have similar
credentials and let me tell you there's
one thing that a hundred percent and you
when do you get a hundred percent of
people agreeing on anything right but I
would say that a hundred percent of
economist a hundred percent of big
finance and economic people people will
really understand it a hundred percent
of them say it's temporary and with good
reason because they've seen other shocks
I saw I think it was Morgan Stanley or
somebody I forget who who said that this
is more like 9/11 than it is like the
slump of 2008-2009 meaning that there
was an external shock but it didn't
really change all our resources and
systems except in you know that little
area then our security got tighter but
basically the economy was still the
economy when we woke up and shook it all
that's our situation now so this virus
is like a neutron bomb it's affecting
people but it didn't break any machines
didn't break any processes the
Internet's gonna work fine so the moment
that we we get the word the the uptick
is going to be just breathtaking you
know the moment your government says you
know we got a handle on this it's safe
to go back to some of your other things
or even if we just figure out to do the
other things better in different ways
the the recovery will be just
breathtaking the only thing we don't
know is when we're going to get the
green light to take the country back to
full health
you know the moment the president says
it's go time people are really ramped up
the other thing I've suggested is we've
got a whole nation that's gonna be stuck
at home for a while and take some
classes if you come at the end of this
and you haven't developed a whole new
skill well you did it wrong you know if
you were out in the job market and you
had let's say some job that got removed
you were a server or whatever well pick
up a new skill find a skill that you can
learn in a few months
that adds well with whatever you do or
whatever you're gonna add later that
makes you more valuable so as your
income comes down you can compensate by
building your skill up while you're
waiting because when you go back you're
gonna go back with a higher skill and
higher income it'll pay for itself so
think of this time off is a little bit
an opportunity for investment in
yourself take an online course the cheap
and widely available